so I am going to bookend this interview
with some positivity the line I it was
uh it was like he took my voice that day
just when I was about to start finding
it every time I've seen the movie it
just absolutely crushes me so to
highlight someone good in your life
early on who is someone that you
encountered at the very beginning of
your career that made you feel you know
seen supported and respected and helped
you take a positive step forward when
you were first starting out and needed
it
oh my gosh what a great question
um that is such a great question
um
I think I mean this is gonna sound
strange but I think that being given
this opportunity
to attempt to play Laura in this movie
has
helped me reclaim part of my voice from
just I don't know it's
that maybe I didn't even realize was
missing
um I don't know it's been very
empowering to to be a part of telling
this story but how in the beginning who
um God
I mean my mother I suppose
uh my mother is an actor and um
I think she's been I think I think her
support has been um has been Monumental
of course I mean I always love when
family supports the answer to stuff like
that I deeply value my family support so
it fills my heart to hear about more of
it out there yeah um let's talk a little
bit about the real Laura Madden so you
you are something else in this movie but
it's a large Ensemble focusing on a lot
of different people so we only get so
much screen time with you so I was
wondering if you found any smaller
details about Laura that maybe weren't
conveyed in dialogue or at the center of
a frame but were important for you to
hold tight to and we could still feel it
informing your performance ah well I
haven't met Laura and I haven't spoken
with her
um so I uh I think that the the moments
as you say they're very that you really
don't have that much time with her
um but that the moments are so
beautifully curated these sort of
Windows into her life these glimpses of
what what the life she has and what
she's going through
um before this even before the
opportunity or The Gauntlet is thrown
down of whether she's going to
um even speak to these journalists let
alone uh have the courage to step
forward and break the silence and go on
the record uh the moments are so
beautifully curated I I know that there
was one moment that I that meant a lot
to me was when I remember Maria said
when um when you say um when you're a
little boy when your daughter says that
your son wants to take his pillow to
Cornwall because we're about to go on
vacation and it was such a lovely little
specific moment because you just get
this this family's about to you know
pack to go the next morning you know
that feeling when you're going to leave
the next morning to go somewhere and
particularly with all these children and
everything and the daughter's like he
wants to take his pillow and um and
Maria was just like oh we're not taking
any pillows you know just do it like and
it was such a wonderful thing to kind of
be just feel like such a real mom in
that moment and I I really just I I like
that I I really I was like oh I think I
I'm getting a sense of this person
though so that was really fun those are
the little things that might not seem
super important in a moment but they
make a world feel real
yeah and it makes you connect too
because I'm sure I've had those
arguments with uh with my mom growing up
and I'm sure my sister's having them
with my niece and nephew right now yes
and it makes me yeah exactly and it
makes a relationship go you know
sometimes you see motherhood portrayed
in
um in stories
um certainly not in this one but in
stories where uh it's all so you know
beautiful was like like this idea of
maternal kind of but that you know love
is um Love is more visceral than that
real true
you know intimacy I have so many
follow-up questions you brought up Maria
so I'll go I'll go there next I was
watching another interview you had done
where I think you said something along
the lines of like like Maria is now a
director for you where if she came
calling you don't even have to read the
script you're just gonna jump in and do
it so it was making me wonder what was
it about the way she worked with her
actors and the way she ran her set that
now has that kind of feeling in your
heart I think that um
I you know I obviously it was a bit it
is a big movie it was a big Studio Movie
it had must have had all the scaffolding
of that it felt very pared down
um actually on the set it felt very
intimate and immediate and
um the the camera felt unobtrusive uh I
really loved
um working with uh Maria I loved working
with her cinematographer
um I
I just yes no I I think you do you work
with directors that you're just like
I'll I'll do that I'll um I'll I'll be
there you know whenever
uh yeah I'm happy to hear she's on that
list I have to I have to talk about the
scene that you share with Zoe because I
I think it is one of the absolute best
scenes that felt like someone asked me
for my reaction right after I walked out
of the movie and the movie is great from
the very beginning but I I legitimately
said to them the second that scene
happens something happened where like
the movie just soared to a very very
special level so it's really something
else that scene is largely on your
shoulder you've got Zoe opposite you
though so what can Zoe be doing for you
as a scene partner in a moment like that
that makes you feel supported and like
you can deliver your best possible work
well I mean she was so
um
she was so present
uh we had just met we had never met
before and we literally just met sitting
at that table
um
and in between we talked a bit about
um motherhood
I think I said um
it's really hard
and she said nobody says that so no I
know but it is
um and uh but I don't know she was she's
just I mean she's such an extraordinary
actor and um to to sit opposite her and
have
um that beautiful bit of the script and
beautiful bit of the story to be a part
of opposite Zoe was just it was a gift
probably one of my favorite scenes of
the entire year and I'm not just saying
it because we're talking right now it
really is something else
um here is my other half of my happy
ending bookend right now so obviously a
lot still needs to change in this
industry but lots of good has happened
so in an effort to emphasize some of
that good change what's something that's
become like an industry Norm now that if
you could go back in time and tell your
younger self one day that thing you want
or need that'll be a given she would be
really happy to hear that
um intimacy coordinators
uh that would have made a huge
difference to my 90s
um I uh that is an extraordinary thing
um we now have a number on our sag card
to call if we
um feel like
something needs to be shared uh
I think that we have just the
communication the dialogue the the sense
of how deep this goes
um in all walks of life uh how deep this
problem goes how whenever there's a
discrepancy of power people are
vulnerable to abuse I think
um the awareness of that just globally
is
um
huge I didn't get the rap sign so I
think I'll squeeze in one more do you
know how much I love your work and I
always want to see more so to highlight
what you have on the horizon is there
any kind of like creative itch or new
technique that Yellowstone is allowing
you to dig into and you're excited to
explore for the first time and excited
to share with uh with your fans for the
first time oh my goodness
um I'm I really I I loved um I loved the
opportunity to be a part of um of 1923
and I'm I'm very excited for it to come
out I am so excited there's this actor I
got to work with called Amina Nieves and
this is
um one of her first jobs and she is
phenomenal and I can't wait for the
world to see her I love hearing about
special people for me to keep my eye out
for I will take that huge huge huge
congratulations on she said I meant
everything I said you are phenomenal in
this film and I can't wait to cover more
of your stuff in the future thank you
Perry I look forward to seeing you in
person at a festival absolutely soon
enough soon enough yes